tout à l'heure vous avez dit que
certaines personnes vous connaissez bien
je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai la
sensation que c'est faux monsieur gré
votre rendez vous est arrivé annulé le
merci nous n'avons pas terminé bien
monsieur non je pense que ça ira je peux
y aller c'est bon je voudrais en savoir
un peu plus sur vous
et myriam captivant à dire à propos de
moi vous êtes une littéraire c'est bien
ça dites moi c'est charlotte brontë jane
austen utp massardier qui vous a donné
le goût de la littérature c'est hardy
j'aurais parié sur jane austen quels
sont vos projets après l'université haut
pour l'instant je me consacre un examen
de fin d'année et ensuite
et ensuite j'ai l'intention de
m'installer ici à seattle avec kate nous
proposons d'excellence tâche pour les
diplômés je ne crois pas que je ferai ma
place ici
regardez moi
je vous regarde